أنا أعتبر نفسي
متفائلاً غاضبًا بمعنى أنني لست سعيدًا
بالوضع الحالي في الطريقة
التي يُعامل بها المسلمون والعديد من الأقليات ،
لكنني متفائل بشكل لا يصدق
بشأن الإمكانات والمرونة التي
تتمتع بها الديمقراطية الأمريكية.  من
بدأ في فهم فكرة
التفاؤل الغاضب عندما حدث حظر السفر عن طريق
وضع مثل هذه اللغة المنمقة
عليه ، فقد صدم الناس بالفعل
لدرجة أنهم مثل الذين
لا أستطيع أن أشاهد فقط أن هذه هي
إعادة الخطبت.  مع هذا ،
قد لا يتمكن جارتي المسلمة من
العودة إلى البلد الذي أسافر إليه ، وسأعود ،
وقد هبطت في مطار جون إف كينيدي ، ثم أرى
كل هؤلاء الأشخاص في قسم الوصول
يركضون نحوي مثل يا أبناء
بوم ، لقد عانقوا  أشكرك يا إلهي يا صاح
لكونك مسلمًا لم يشكرني أحد
على ذلك ، وكنت أشكرك
يا تشاد ، لكنك تريد أن تأتي للصلاة
حرفيًا كما لو كان البيض يمسكون
بأيديهم حول مسلمين يصلون في
قسم الوصول في  المطار
كان حرفياً رؤية شيء يقول
شيئًا ما وكل شخص رأى
شيئًا وكان مثل هذا
مذهلًا ، هذا ما تدور حوله أمريكا
حتى في مواجهة
الرعب الهائل والإرهاب والأشياء الفظيعة التي
تحدث هناك
إمكانية هائلة للتغيير و  لكي
يتجمع الناس معًا ويكافحون من أجل
الأشياء الصحيحة
أوه